and the thing with walker is the average
for the giants goes down on the elevated
fastball once it's 95 plus and guess
what that's where he lives
and has against them they're one for 14
against that pitch when it is up in the
zone
wave junior swings at the first pitch of
the game and rifles one out of the left
center field it gets by aj pollock and
that's a good start for the giants it's
a leadoff double man at third nobody out
here in the first inning seven pitch
coming here to posey
got him to chase the cutter so now
yastremski and the infield does come in
yes
down the left field line that should be
plenty deep enough aj pollock
short of the warning track wade will tag
the throw is going to come in much too
late and nice job mike kustremski giants
grab a one nothing lead anthony
diesclervani
take a look at the numbers for anthony d
stefani start number 20. he's 10-4 in
here with a 2-7-80 ra against the rest
of baseball he's got a 1-7-8 bra three
games against la it's 11.
taylor shoots andre basic to center on
97 to open the nine
first and third nobody out dodgers
threatening to tie it just like that
with turner coming up
and he shoots one through three straight
singles tied at one
what a great response to being down 1-0
there's the pitch swinging and i miss he
struck it out with a cutter that ran off
the outside and that is the first out of
the inning now here's matt beatty
another one too baby on the ground to
second can the giants turn two that's
one that's two double played that was a
big one laid off man has been on both
innings for the giants that have been
solano now
bounces this one up the middle muncie
there with a backhand to get the out at
second laid at first
tremendous play to get the lead runner
by max muncie solana with third duggar
at first one gone and a tie game in the
second strikeout would be big here for
mueller got him swinging big strikeout
for walker bueller his second of the
night is out number two in the second so
he strikes out as strata and if you can
get these scufagio keep this a one-one
game and an o2 from walker buehler he
strikes him out sticking to the fastball
and getting out of the indian scale cody
bellinger for the dodgers to start the
second
2-2
got the call right on the outside corner
same pitch he got first strike with he
comes back again back door and that's
cutter aj [ __ ] has had a good month
hitting for a lot of power
on the ground to short tyro estrada
two down
that one hit well to center field
duggar over with roone and it's one two
three innings walker bueller against dee
sclafani
kind of looking third strikeout for
declining out number one
now chris taylor here's the 2-2
that one to center field duggar will
come in and make the catch muncie who
had a hit in the first inning this
lafani's one-two pitch swing and him as
he struck him out with a slider at the
knees and the inning is over four
strikeouts for disc lefty lead off man
on for the third time in four innings
for the giants dickerson an infield hit
in his first stat back uses the cutter
to finish dickerson off finally fourth
game for buehler one gone
one on one out here's solano
off the end of the bat back to buehler
the second one muncie to first two
he faces the minimum in the fourth
will smith
way up there to deep center field did he
get enough he got plenty
two-run shot 3-1 dodgers
second home run for will smith against
anthony d stefani second home run of the
series
he coils and then he unloads and even
when he unloads it's not aggressive he
has such a smooth swing also stays very
compact
but when he gets his extension it goes a
long way
pollock with two down got an enfield hit
he's at first
diving wade's got it
inning over the walker fielder he faced
the minimum thanks to the double play
ball last jimmy bottom third of the
order here's stephen duggar and down
swinging on a chain jump
good movement on the change up
when you throw 97 it looks like it could
be that but then you get that movement
wow there are not bats long enough to
reach that
track out number five for bueller
coming right at him and striking him out
and 11 pitches a one two three fifth for
the dodgers walker bueller leads off
chased and missed one away
stefanie strikeout number five one out
and chris taylor comes up
oh man that one with that movement
coming back to the outside at 95 he
strikes him out swinging the sixth
inning we go walker bueller chilemont
wade jr
on the hands of wade
baity to the bag one gone
and buster posey is over two stepping in
posey pulls it to third turner across
the diamond beady comes to get it and
tags posey
good play by justin turner two gone in
the sixth
the stremski's at third with two out it
was a ball and a strike wilmer flores
who grounds it to third
turner goes to first and the inning is
over listen walker builders got six k's
one walk the long run that he allowed
was in the first inning fueler trying to
stay perfect against the giants not just
this season but in his five-year big
league career
that one's in there no question
two-seamer comes back to get him that
one is rock solid strike for bueller his
seventh strike out of the game donovan
solano 1-2
back-to-back strikeout still from the
seventh
and eighth total tonight
two out nobody on dodgers three to one
two two
and strikes him out looking back door
cutter to strike out the side and bring
a smirk from bueller walker butter one
run over seven innings that long run
came in the first he struck out nine
he's walked one he gets a first pitch
swinging from tyro estrada one pitch one
out giants get the tying run to the
plate in the former lamont wade he is
gonna take him out
dave roberts not gonna take any chances
here with a tying run at the plate
and the top of the order coming up to
facing the fourth time
a well-deserved hand from a crowd of 47
000 plus not out of the woods yet in
fact far from it
as buster posey climbs in representing
the tying run
off the end of the back to shore taylor
calmly fields lobs a throw and gets him
the amount of trying to close it out is
this kind of storybook of the series
some pages good some pages bad kenley
janssen when he comes back home to
strike him out on three pitches
giants get the time run up there and up
comes dickerson ready for another 2-2
pitch
here it comes
he struck him out
turning it up to 96 with a two seen two
going in the night
giants down to their last out
estrada game on the line flores at third
talk minute second wassler first estrada
on the ground is short taylor's got it
he'll go to second
and he just got him
and i think the giants are definitely
going to want to look at this
if the call was correct the game's over
i think he might have been safe here we
go
call safe and there you have it wow so
run has scored on a ground ball that
looked like it would end the game
now the tying run is at third another
3-2 from jansen
and did he go
no
game tied it's ball four unbelievable
and dave roberts is losing his mind
he's thrown out and he's gonna go get
his money's worth from first base on
fire ed hickox
a swing it's where the bat travels and
here comes lamont way junior
wade into right field and it's a base
hit
vossler in here comes estrada he'll
score five to three giants
unbelievable
he takes a cut right off the hands and
chances that's exactly where he wanted
to throw it
five straight to our base runners and
the same song as last night as jansen
leaves the field two down dodgers are
down to their final out giants are one
out away from a remarkable night
pitches
got him swinging
and just an amazing come-from-behind win
the giants win the game they win the
series and they're three games up in the
national league west